The Surprisingly Short History of the Pony
Express
Given that most have still heard of the Pony
Express today, unlike so many other messaging
companies long gone, you may think that the
Pony Express was once an integral part of
communication between the East and West in
the United States.
It turns out, this was never the case and
the Pony Express was around only for an extremely
short amount of time.
It all started on April 3, 1860, when two
riders, one in Sacramento, California, the
other in St. Joseph, Missouri, simultaneously
embarked on a mirror-like mission – carry
mail across the difficult and dangerous terrain
of the American West in the shortest amount
of time possible.
With each load (including the riders) weighing
no more than 165 pounds, the two men reached
the others’ starting point in record time:
the westbound rider made it to Sacramento
in just under 10 days, while the eastbound
man reached St. Joseph in 11.5.
Together, these journeys marked the beginning
of the Pony Express.
The brainchild of visionary businessman William
Russell, the Leavenworth & Pike’s Peak Express
Company (later to be known as the Pony Express)
was born of two desires: (1) people’s need
to communicate and (2) a businessman’s need
for profit.
By the 1850s, hundreds of thousands of Americans
had migrated to live west of the Rocky Mountains.
Remember that by this time, California had
seen its great Gold Rush, the Mormons had
fled religious persecution and were settling
in Utah in large numbers, and thousands of
pioneers had made the arduous trek of the
Oregon Trail over the high mountains to homestead
in the West.
Before the Pony Express, it could take up
to 8 weeks for a letter from the eastern U.S.
to reach these westerners since most mail
was shipped by boat.
The few letters that went overland only cut
that time by half, and then only by taking
a southern route for mail service – out
of Fort Smith, Arkansas, with stops in El
Paso, Texas, and Yuma, Arizona, before arriving
in San Francisco, California, three to four
weeks later.
As you can imagine, anyone who had a need
for transcontinental communication was soon
frustrated by the extraordinarily long delivery
time, and just as long for a reply.
Coinciding with the national desire for speedier
mail service was Russell’s need for a new
source of income.
Together with his partners, William Bradford
and Alexander Majors, Russell ran a stage
coach and freight business out of Leavenworth,
Kansas that by the late 1850s was floundering.
While on a trip to Washington, he pitched
an idea to California’s Senator William
Gwin – to quickly deliver mail via an overland
central route that followed the Oregon and
California trails.
The key to his speedy delivery was to be a
system of hundreds of way stations where fresh
horses and riders would be continuously substituted
all along the 1,800 mile trail.
The route itself began in St. Joseph, Missouri,
followed the Platte and Sweetwater rivers,
then crossed the Rockies via the South Pass
to Salt Lake City, Utah.
From there, the riders crossed the deserts
of Utah and Nevada, then went over the Sierra
Nevada Mountains and finally landed in California
– all in about 10 days.
Hundreds of men were hired to manage the way
stations where fresh horses (between 400 and
500 total) and riders (about 80) would be
waiting to relieve a tired courier.
The riders themselves had to be small, under
120 pounds, and the mail bags were limited
to 20 pounds, all to keep the weight the horses
had to bear to a minimum (which, with equipment
and mail, was capped at 165 pounds).
The couriers, who were paid $25 per week (about
$640 today), were given a distinctive uniform
of red shirt and blue pants, and at first,
they blew a brass horn to signal their impending
arrival at a way station.
This last was soon discarded, however, when
it became clear that the approaching hoof
beats provided sufficient notice.
For maximum efficiency, a station was placed
every 10-15 miles for the riders to switch
horses, and then after every 75-100 miles,
the couriers themselves would be replaced.
The enterprise was intended to make a profit,
and Russell and his partners had hoped Uncle
Sam would ultimately subsidize the venture.
It didn’t, and even though the Express initially
charged $5 per half-ounce of mail (today’s
U.S. Post Office charges $0.49 for up to 13
ounces for first class delivery), the Pony
Express operated at a significant loss.
Its end came quickly – just 19 months after
it started, when it was replaced with better
technology.
Beginning in June 1860 (only two months after
the first Pony Express ride), telegraph lines
to connect the East and West Coasts were begun
by the Pacific Telegraph Company coming out
of Nebraska and the Overland Telegraph Company
from California.
On October 24, 1861, the transcontinental
telegraph was up and running and two days
later, the Pony Express officially ended.
A great idea, but bad timing.
Bonus Facts:
• Though not called spam back then, telegraphic
spam messages were extremely common in the
19th century in the United States particularly.
Western Union allowed telegraphic messages
on its network to be sent to multiple destinations.
Thus, wealthy American residents tended to
get numerous spam messages through telegrams
presenting unsolicited investment offers and
the like.
This wasn’t nearly as much of a problem
in Europe due to the fact that telegraphy
was regulated by post offices in Europe.
• Buffalo Bill Cody (1846-1917) was a Pony
Express rider.
Outside of riding for the Pony Express, he
is estimated to have killed around 20,000
bison (often called “Buffalo,” even though
they are not) in his lifetime.
For reference, one single hide in good condition
would bring in about $3.
Made into a winter coat, it could bring in
as much as $50.
Ironically, Buffalo Bill was one of the most
outspoken supporters of plans to protect the
bison populations through legislation.
In the end, President Grant vetoed the bill
that would have protected the herds, due to
the frequent small wars the U.S. had to fight
with the Plains Indians.
By getting rid of the bison herds, it took
away the Plains Indians primary food and clothing
source.
• A common myth surrounding American Bison
is that there were massive herds before the
Europeans came to America, on the scale that
Americans eventually encountered them at.
In fact, evidence suggests that the Native
Americans naturally kept the bison populations
regulated by various means.
After the European diseases wiped out most
of the Native Americans, the American Bison
population exploded, becoming the most numerous
large wild mammal on Earth until eventually
hunted to near extinction within a few centuries
after this population explosion.
At their peak, it was estimated that there
were nearly 100 million American Bison in
existence, only a few centuries ago.
• The fastest delivery every made by the
Pony Express was President Lincoln’s inauguration
address that was delivered in less than 8
days.
• The first telegram sent, on May 26, 1844,
was from Samuel Morse (who invented the code)
and read, “What Hath God Wrought?”